learning typescript using react can be
tough
figuring out all the different types to
use figuring out how to correctly
define your components can be
challenging especially if you're just
starting out
your typescript journey by jumping in to
typescript from the start
so i'm here to help we're going to go
and look step by step
at how to define your components using
typescript and we're going to go to some
places you might not have even seen
before like how to use
generics in your typescript components
which makes them even cooler and easier
to use so
let's jump right into it all right
so we're back at it now we're going to
look at typescript
and react and the first thing we're
going to look at is this
cheat sheet this is an awesome cheat
sheet
it's actually going to cover a lot more
than i'm going to cover in this
but i think i'm going to cover the
components part in this video at a bit
more level of detail
and talk about some of the edge cases
and some of the more unique ways
to define your react components
and let's get after it so the first
thing we're going to do is
create our react app and to do that i'm
going to use create react app
i'm not going to do it quite the same
way as they have it here but you can
certainly
feel free to do it this way as well i'm
just going to use the template for
create react app so let's bring up our
terminal
and i'm going to go into my temp
directory and then i'm going to use yarn
create
react app and i'll give it a name of i
guess
ts for typescript cra for create react
app and
i guess just test it's fine and then i'm
going to go back to that
cheat sheet and grab the template
because that's the same so it's dash
dash
template type script i'll paste that in
there
and that's going to go build out the
standard create react
app is going to look exactly the same as
your normal create react app except that
it's going to be
dot tsx files as opposed to jsx files
t being typescript and then on the
ts5 there's going to be you have ts
instead of js
so but in this case i think it's
actually all
tsx because the
anytime you have jsx syntax inside of a
file
you have to use the extension tsx which
is
not as there's not it's not as stringent
on the jsi but it is
on the typescript side so all right
let's bring up
let's go into that directory and then
bring up vs code
and let's have a look around so over
here in our source directory
yep we got those tsx files so anytime
that you use the jsx syntax which means
that you're putting
what looks like html what is actually
creating javascript for you
that javascript jsx syntax in there you
have to use the extension.tsx
and it looks like well a couple of
things over here with the ts but
otherwise
mostly tsx so let me go and pair this
down
because we don't really need all that
and then i'll make the css a little bit
easier to use so i'll make that margin
auto
make the uh maximum size of this 800
just so we can put in kind of in the
middle of the screen
and then make the font size xx large
just so we can all
see it and there we go that's the only
changes i'm gonna make let's
fire this up okay so an empty screen
how exciting is that so first thing
we're gonna do is create a
heading component let's just try that
out first so
i'm going to use let's call this
conventional props
and we'll do a we'll make a heading so
call that
function heading
and it's going to take a title
so how do we define what a title should
be well we'll just use the standard
object definition in typescript so in
this case i'll we'll do title string
so in this case we're saying that we
want to destructure this object
coming in but the object itself needs to
be defined
as a title as a string
and you can go and make a parameter
optional by just doing question mark
if you want and then return out
let's just say an h1 with that title
but this isn't in the children right
it's a parameter it's a property so
let's move that back
to here title equals hello there
and let's take a look okay pretty good
pretty good so far so what do i get out
of this while i get hinting so if i were
to go and bring up
code hinting i get title in there and it
tells me and then if i were to go put in
like a 2
it would tell me no no that's not the
right thing number is not assignable to
a string
i can put in hello but that's that's
really a little verbose i don't really
need all that so
just go back with title hello just like
that
pretty easy so the other thing we like
to do
in react is to use
children and have have children
properties so
i have have a container so i'm going to
basically create this
where the title in this case would be
the whatever the child element is in
there so
call this heading again but this time
we'll say it's with content
and we'll say that there's children
and that children well we'll start off
with a string how does that work so
heading content
hi okay let's see if that works
no it does that's pretty cool so it'll
automatically make sure that that's a
piece of string but if i were to do
something like uh
strong hi
all right does that work no it doesn't
work because the type of element
is not assignable to a string so it's
expecting the children as a string when
it's
not so what i like to do is actually use
react
node in here
that brings it in from here and this
will pretty much take
really anything and another question is
kind of what is this actually going to
return well you don't really need to
worry about that too much
typescript is going to handle that for
you but if you are interested in
in that i tend to use react
element as the output here uh but in
reality it's a react element or null
is kind of what it's expecting so but in
this case
we're only going to return a a react
element so
there you go this is like one of the
things that a lot of people run into
right away which is
if you're going to be building a ui
framework that has you know container
classes and stuff like that
the ability to go and define what is
actually supposed to be in the content
is is really important okay so
another thing that trips people up is
default props so let's talk about that
for a second
so let's say i want to build another
container
and i want to have a heading but the
heading is going to have a
default in it so i'm going to say let's
set up that container first
and have container and it's going to
take a heading
and that heading is going to be a
also react node like that
and now let's actually try this out
container foo right and
well that's a problem because we don't
have a heading in there so
what i want to do is have a default for
that so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to create
a new constant we'll call it
default container props
and then we'll set the heading to
a strong with my heading in it just like
that cool
and the next thing i'm going to do is
define take these guys
well actually here's there's a there's a
couple of different ways to do this let
me do it
the sort of grungiest way first i'm
going to take this out
and then i'm going to use and
type of default container prop so what
this is going to do
is you can merge two types together to
create kind of
a composite type so in this take in this
case it's taking this
react node here and it's adding on this
the types that are defined in this
constant so that would be a
heading probably a react node or react
element
in there now i'll go and add that
heading in there as well
so let's do div
make the heading in h1
and then put this in as just the
children that's fine
oops sort of bounce around like that
but now how do i actually get them to be
the default props so get to
do container dot default props
and then just give it that default
container props
okay let's see if that works so ideally
if i haven't actually put a heading on
there
it'll automatically give me well what
does it say
my heading okay so we're expecting my
heading with a contents of foo so let's
see if that worked
yep it did that's great okay cool
awesome
a nicer way to do this i would say would
be to define it like this
grab this out say type we'll say call
this
container props and then just
paste that back in there put that like
that
and you know i think that's a little bit
cleaner more readable for sure
cool okay now if we go back to
our cheat sheet we actually have gotten
pretty far into
section two around getting started and
this is defining what the
the functional components are and i just
want to point out this
this section here which is around
react.fc
so you might see this in code
let's take for example this one heading
and call it fc heading or something like
that you might see something like this
const heading fc
and then defined as react.fc
and then in here you you put the title
string
and then for this you'd have title
and the rest of it pretty much falls on
from there so
take that out there okay
so this works but it's not considered
the state of the art and that's actually
what that cheat sheet is telling you is
this is
kind of the old way to do it uh the only
thing that that's really adding
is adding a default prop for children
which you know you may or may not want
you know if you don't want to support
children
if you do it this way where
you're just saying i only want a title
then
if somebody tries to wrap some child
elements inside of a heading it's going
to blow up on them so that's great
so this allows you to much more
granularly define
what exactly what you want in your
properties whether that's children or
whatever
all right so let's continue on kind of
digging a little bit deeper down
than that cheat sheet does i'm going to
take this out
yeah okay now we're just down to the uh
just down to the code
and we're gonna start talking about
functional properties
so add a new comment functional props
and in this case i'm going to go and
create a
a component that has a button in it
but what is rendered in the component
is actually defined by a function which
is pretty interesting
so let's call this text with
number and then what are my properties
so my properties are
children which in this case i'm going to
define
as a function
and that function is going to take a
number
and then return back a react node
and i'll create some state in here
now i'm not going to get into a full
discussion about
about state or state managers in this
particular video
this is mostly about components but the
way that you define
what you'd expect to see in this state
would be either
i could do that like a one in this case
or a number right i'm expecting a number
and this is going to work for me because
that's basically
uh that's the equivalent of just saying
i want a number in there
right but if you've got a state where
this could be null for example
like it might start off by null and then
become a number once you get some data
back or something like that
what you need to do is do number or null
right so just like you can do
and with types and create composite
types
you can create or types using that or
so in this case i really do want a
number
so i'll return a div
and then within that another div that
has a button in it
call that add an on click
then when you click it it just does a
state set
with the state plus one and then in here
for the content
i'm actually going to use that child
function
with that number so state
so let's give this a try so i'm going to
go down here
text with number and then in the
child spot instead of giving it some
actual
react elements or strings or whatever
what have you
i'm actually going to put a function in
here so that's going to take and you can
see
it's going to it actually wants me to do
this i'll bring that up
it's saying that children is supposed to
be a num number
or a function that takes a number so
let's do that
today's
is no
all right let's give that a go
nice okay so really pretty nice
uh interface there i've seen a lot of
these kind of functional components
with animation libraries stuff where you
know
you've got a container that's actually
managing some state like this this
number in this case
and then it's calling back to you to do
the rendering but that rendering needs
to change
based on that state so
same sort of thing with a prop with a
header prop let's bring that
try that too so we'll have a header
all right and
let's just say that we have
a header in there we'll call it
h2 or h3 whatever header
and then also state okay
now this is incomplete so the way we do
that is say header
and then give it a call back again very
clean interface
so again num number and we're gonna
return
you know uh let's just say
uh span with you know header
no nopes don't need that that
okay there we go okay
and now if i click on that everything's
great
cool well how do i make this optional
interesting question so in that case i
can just do
question mark dot like that
and that way that will only get called
if there
is an actual header element so if i were
to remove that at this point
it's not going to blow up but it is
going to put an empty h
2 in there because these guys are going
to be unconditionally rendered
where this one is just conditionally
rendered so if i wanted to do that i
could just
say if i have a header then do that
there you go so there you go optional
chaining to make sure that you only call
the function if it's there
otherwise that looks great cool
another thing that they don't cover in
that and i think is actually really
important and i actually saw a lot of
this in the aws
ui exploration we did
a couple weeks back and was
generics around functions so
let's go let's try that so i'm going to
make a list
function component and
that function we'll call it i guess list
and it's going to take items and it's
going to take a render function
right so the idea is it's going to
manage the list for me
and then it's going to
call render on every item in that list
so how am i going to define this well
items
is going to be something we don't know
quite what it is yet
right so what you do is you make a
generic so i'm going to say that
it is of a let's see list item
when it's an array of list items
so over here i'm going to say that part
of our template is that we want
a we're going to take whatever the type
is on items here and that becomes list
item
and then i can reuse that and i say when
i render
i'm going to pass an item well how's
that going to be defined what's going to
be defined as
a list item and it's going to return
a react node just like that
so now we actually have to define this
it's actually pretty easy to find
so let me do return and then i'll create
an unordered list take all the
items map through them
get back an item and an index
give the key as an index
and then now what do i do well i need to
call that render function right
so i'm going to render and give it that
item
pretty cool huh so i go down here i go
to list
i'm going to try this out
so what do i need well i need items
and that's going to be array let's say
jack
uh sadie oso
and my render is
a function and check it out so it's
already telling me that i'm going to
take
a string so it's gone and looked at the
type
that was in that items knowing that it
was an array of strings
right and it's taken that string because
that's now list item list item in this
case is string
and it's applied that to render so now
render
takes a string
which is a string i don't really need to
define that
but i'm going to because why not and i'm
going to put in there a div
and it's going to have the item to lower
case
just to show off that it's an actual
string so everything in here
should be a lowercased string
let's take like yep that worked just
fine so that's that's a really
nice way to define this
this class right this this actually
really kind of extends
the functionality of react by allowing
us to to do this kind of
generic functions i think that's that's
really cool okay so the last thing i
want to cover
before i wrap this up is to talk about
class-based components now we don't do a
lot of these anymore if you are doing
class-based components
probably shouldn't be but and
i think one of the only valid areas is
around error boundaries but still it's
good to know
so let's try that out so let's create a
class
component and how to strongly or
typescriptize those
so starts off pretty simple class let's
say my container
extends react. component
we know this we've seen this before
but in typescript you can do a generic
and you can say great okay so my
property the first item in this
is the properties the second item is the
state well i'm not going to put any
state you can see p for properties s for
state
um i'm just going to use properties in
this case and we're going to say that
again we have a heading a header which
is a react node
what's this you know what let's just
call this my heading
because all the stuff that was working
there before
is going to work in this too
all the stuff that was working with the
components and the functional components
is going to work here as well so
let's just create that render function
if you've
never seen one of these so much the
better for you really
and then return and then we'll do
an h1 with that title
again in the case of a class component
like this you got to use this.props
and then check it out we've already got
title ready to go
just drop that in there and now we can
do my header
it's not happy because i haven't put in
a title i think let's take a look yep
title there you go
there you go
that out hey
rockin okay
so there you go let's just go back up
from the start again so we've got
our support for conventional properties
right these are pretty simple
so if we just give it you know the list
of the of the different properties
you've got and then
in the next section the the different
types that you have associated with
those properties
for children you're probably going to
want react node we can actually go
over and check the uh the definition of
that that can be all kinds of cool stuff
child fragment portal boolean null and
undefined
pretty pretty wide spectrum there of
things that could be
and then down here we start to talk
about default props
so here's a nice little pattern for you
it's really backed up by that cheat
sheet
so you're defining the default container
props and then you're using the type of
that so you don't need to redefine that
you're letting that defined for you
in combination with children if you
don't use children in this case then you
don't have to bring that in you can just
use the type of that
then you're reusing that definition of
container props
here again we can also get rid of that
that's that's basically defined but
we can we can keep that around if we
want and then
setting the default props so they're
actually functional
in this case right and then we get into
functional props so this is one where
you're sending a function
instead of either an array or a react
node you're sending a function that will
in turn create react nodes
um and then you get to define what that
the api signature of that function
and that output and then this is how you
do the same one for any kind of prop
that is a function
and then the really interesting one i
say about generics
so we're defining a list component
we are defining it as a generic so there
are parts of this
api signature that are generic in this
case the list item
we're expecting an array of those list
items and a render
that takes that list item type and
returns a react node and the great thing
about this
is completely reusable that list item
could be a pokemon
it could be a string it could be all
kinds of things
and it's going to go in and render that
out for you so this is a really
really really nice pattern if you are a
a component
designer or somebody who's working on a
component library
i mean really really have a good look at
this one i think this is a great
thing and i i really appreciate seeing
it in that aws ui library
and then finally into class components
you have the header with the title
and uh yeah it's pretty pretty standard
stuff but this
is how you define props again the second
thing would be
if you would have any state you could
define that in here as well
all right there you have it typescript
and
react all right i hope you enjoyed that
i hope you learned a lot about how to
define your react components
using typescript and all the different
variants
therein i think that template one is
really interesting so that'll be
interesting to see
if any questions or comments or further
clarifications
to make be sure to put those in that
comment section down below
or you can jump on the discord server
there's a typescript channel in there to
talk about it
and while you're there you should check
out the jmusic community project was
turned out to be a
blast we're doing a lot of fun stuff in
the music space
creating an algorithmic chord book which
is really cool
and putting a fun glassmorphic interface
on it using
state-of-the-art tools tailwind and all
the rest it's
great stuff lots of fun come on and
check it on out
in the meantime of course feel free to
like and share this video with your
friends hit that subscribe button if you
haven't already
but in the meantime be happy be healthy
and be safe